if you look at the people quote unquote
have good willpower habits there there's
some really interesting pieces there one
is they actually find things that they
enjoy doing so people you know people do
something like eat healthy or exercise
if you ask them why they do it the
people that are really good at doing it
and you probably know this personally
it feels good yeah as compared to oh I
need to get in shape to get a you know
my body looking this way for them it's
not like an intellectual exercise not at
all and that's that part makes sense but
that's not willpower and it makes sense
because that is reward-based learning
we're doing something out of the reward
of doing it not because we're doing it
so that's one of the big misconceptions
around willpower is that if you look at
reward-based learning it's based on the
reward it's not based on the behavior
itself so if it were the behavior we
just say stop doing this but it's
actually the reward that drives future
behavior and that's where we can start
to intervene